(Record scratch)
(Music starts)
I don't see a problem
I'll draw you a map,
meet you when I can.
I gotta follow my own path,
and welcome what finds me
right where I am.
And if you're gonna love me tomorrow,
maybe you could love me today.
The love songs and poetry you borrow,
picks me up, carries me away.
But I'd like to look farther
than the sun on Saturday.
And if I hold on tight,
I might not fall and float away.
I don't wanna lose my place.
I'm catching a break now.
I'm chipping away at the brightest gold.
I gotta see it for myself,
and let it become a sight to behold.
And if you're gonna love me tomorrow,
maybe you could love me today.
You get lost in the pretty afterglow,
picks you up, carries you away.
I'm not looking for a big distraction anyway.
I'll climb up to the top
and yell out all I have to say.
Why can't that start today?
(Music)
You're gonna love me, yeah!
'Cause I'm catching a break now.
(Music)
I'm catching a break now.
(Music ends)